la reprise dans les transports trafic à
peu près normal à la ratp à la sncf en
question le prix de la grève pour les
usagers qui seront remboursés sous
certaines conditions
quant aux grévistes il pourrait voir
étaler la retenue de leurs jours de
grève
le bac français aujourd'hui plus de 625
mille candidats une épreuve dans le
calme sans dérapage les élèves qui dans
d'autres classes retrouve le cheval
d'école avec un certain retard à
rattraper
à bunia au congo les milices utilisent
des enfants soldats qui ont à peine 12
ans il manie des armes de guerre et ont
appris à tuer un document dans ce
journal
et puis on a pris 10 à moins d'une heure
la mort de l'animateur d' intervilles
guy lux était un âge de 84 ans il aura
marqué pendant plus de 40 ans l'histoire
de la télé avec à son actif plus d'une
cinquantaine dé nice
voilà monsieur bonsoir en ce début de
week-end je vous propose d'ouvrir ce
journal par la bataille engagée par le
gouvernement contre la violence routière
et en particulier les excès de vitesse
paru au journal officiel aujourd'hui la
loi autorise l'utilisation de nouveaux
radars totalement automatisées qui
seront désormais répartis avant la fin
de l'année dans 30 départements les
contraventions seront plus nombreuses
plus rapide et envoyées automatiquement
propriétaire démonstration grandeur
nature avec ce reportage au tunnel du
fréjus benoît gadret jean claude martin
tunnel du mont-blanc tunnel du fréjus
deux ouvrages où l'on teste depuis
quelques mois les nouveaux radars fixes
numérique à peine flash et le conducteur
en infraction apparaît sur un ordinateur
au pc sécurité
il n'y a plus de pellicules à développer
il attendait tout seul c'est un homme
qui conduit il sera interpellé à la
sortie du tunnel efficace et dissuasif
au tunnel du fréjus le nouveau radar a
fait chuter le nombre d'infractions
on a démarré avec 15 cents par semaine
on en est rendu à 500 donc on peut
imaginer que
bientôt on aura encore moins
d'infractions pour en constater que
pratiquement plus radars fixes est
désormais radar numérique mobile voici
le tout nouvel équipement des gendarmes
une petite caméra numérique enregistre
les infractions sur une disquette à la
brigade le gendarme reporte le tout sur
son pc et en quelques secondes à l'aide
de la plaque d'immatriculation il
imprime l'avis de contravention
le titulaire de la carte grise ne reçoit
donc la fraction le lendemain voir le
surlendemain des pv plus rapide
trois fois plus nombreux à terme les
nouveaux radars seront installés aux
endroits stratégiques les points choisis
seront principalement des points où il
ya une forte de nombreux accidents où il
ya une forte accidentologie et il y aura
des dispositifs fixes et également des
dispositifs mobiles dans des véhicules
banalisés d'ici la fin de l'année 30
radars mobiles et 70 fixes seront
installés en france dans trois ans il y
en aura mille ceci nous amène à ce grave
accident sur l'autoroute a10 à semi
remorque a traversé le terre-plein
central
la voiture est arrivée en sens inverse a
été percuté deux personnes ont effectué
deux autres blessés le chauffeur du
poids lourd est indemne et est interrogé
par les gendarmes on ignore les raisons
pour l'instant de l'accident l'autoroute
a10 à hauteur de blois été coupée
pendant plus de deux heures dans le sens
paris province
elle n'est pas encore ouverte à l'heure
qu'il est dans le sens province-paris
fugues à répétition pour ce jeune
adolescent placé dans un centre éducatif
fermé en gironde c'est la troisième fois
que ce garçon 15 ans sans fuite cet
établissement pour délinquants mineurs
cette affaire souligne le manque de
formation de l'encadrement c'était
d'ailleurs l'une des critiques les plus
fréquentes qui avait été opposé à la
création de ces centres récemment créé
apple de genève car une femme à peine de
retour et déjà en fuite
ils étaient près de 21h hier soir quand
deux adolescents fugué du centre
éducatif fermé
parmi eux abdelkader 15 ans et demi
repris la veille après déjà un mois de
fuguer un cambriolage autour du centre
les riverains sont excédés
hier soir c'est le personnel qui était
montré du doigt le président du conseil
général nous a fait passer les
qualifications du personnel il s'avère
qu'ils sont pas du tout ils n'ont pas du
tout les compétences requises pour ce
genre d'activités s'agissant du
d'expérience à mon avis elle est
concluante maintenant il faut fermer le
document le voici le président du
conseil général y écrit entre autres que
le directeur ne possède pas une
formation qualifiante de directeur
d'établissement sociale nous avons
contacté la direction du centre
selon elle les centres éducatifs fermés
demande d'autres qualifications que
celle d'éducateur spécialisé pour
l'avocat du fugueur l'erreur a été
commise dès le départ son client
n'aurait jamais dû revenir au centre
c'est une sorte de fuite en avant et le
fait qu'il ait pu se jouer comme ça de
toutes ces injonctions et de cette
inefficacité d'un centre fermé qui est
pas vraiment fermé qui juridique
confirmé mais réellement ouvert et bien
a fait qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte
de l'incohérence de ce type de procédure
pour l'administration en revanche pas
question de faire machine arrière
c'est loin d'être un constat d'échec lé
dispositif n'est pas du tout remis en
cause car comme je vous l'indiquais tout
à l'heure nous prenons en charge ici des
mineurs qui n'était pris en charge par
personne ce soir les deux fuyards sont
toujours activement recherchés
tout comme un autre pensionnaire du
centre qui lui a fugué la semaine
dernière parmi les nouveaux dispositifs
destinés à combattre l'économie
souterraine dans les quartiers sensibles
les groupes régionaux d'intervention
l'hégire dont nicolas sarkozy adressé
aujourd'hui un bilan très élogieux
reste à savoir quelle sera l'efficacité
à long terme de ces unités spéciales
dans un domaine qui est particulièrement
complexe puisqu'il s'agit de démanteler
les trafics en tous genres le point zine
dine boudaoud edouard paiera les 28
patron des gir le savait qu'ils seraient
jugés sur des résultats aujourd'hui
le ministre de l'intérieur les a tous
réunis pour leur présenter le bilan de
leur première année d'activité 372
opération 3076 interpellation près de 5
millions d'euros saisis des chiffres
censés faire taire toute contestation
quand on innove
il ya des polémiques j'ai essayé de
laisser passer ces polémiques et j'ai
pensé que la meilleure réponse à ces
polémiques c'était les résultats
aujourd'hui force est de constater qu'il
n'y a pas de polémique et que plus
personne ne demande la suppression des
gir la polémique a d'abord porté sur la
méthode trop spectaculaire pour certains
aujourd'hui c'est le résultat qui est
parfois critiquée en février dernier
policiers gendarmes douaniers
interviennent à colombes objectif
démanteler un réseau de trafiquants de
drogue qui se cachait à peine les cela
n'a pas fait taire les opposants trois
mois après on est obligé de constater
que les trafiquants sont réinstallées
c'était deux culées belgique est donc
mais en tout cas pour les habitants du
quartier les mêmes nuisances sauf pour
se poursuivre dans les gir plusieurs
administrations différentes apprennent à
travailler ensemble
certaines commencent à douter de la
portée de leurs propres enquêtes par
exemple au fisc je pense qu'il a
beaucoup plus une opération de publicité
autour de cette action que réelle
efficacité en termes de lutte contre la
fraude les fraudes et la fraude fiscales
notamment
ces critiques ne semble guère atteindre
le ministre de l'intérieur l'existence
des gir n'est pas remise en cause
au contraire un 29e groupe va être créé
apparu l'agression du proviseur d'un
collège près de rouen la principale a
été gravement blessée mais rien à voir
avec les mouvements de ces dernières
semaines ni de la violence en milieu
scolaire en fait il s'agit d'un tragique
fait divers
luc ferry s'est rendu au chevet de la
victime le reportage florence greffant
vincent ferreira
la nouvelle a très vite fait le tour du
collège provoquant l'incompréhension et
l'indignation à 19 heures hier
l'établissement était désert seule la
principale travail est encore dans son
blouson
un jeune d'une vingtaine d'années s'est
alors présentée dans le couloir en
prétextant une inscription
administrative la suite c'est ça colle
et qui la raconte
roué de coups de coups de pied
il ya dans la cour en laye et les
chaises pliantes y avait une chasse aux
clients qui a été quasi utilisée par
l'agresseur n'a toujours pas été
identifié pour la police il s'agirait
uniquement d'un acte crapuleux
ça n'a pas pour nous à priori le
caractère de violence scolaire
rien ne le demande et tout démontre au
contraire qu'un sac à main a été volée
fouillé et les le contenu en partie
brûlé quoi qu'il en soit luc ferry est
venue quelques minutes témoigner de son
soutien au professeur
vu le contexte actuel l'accueil a été
extrêmement sobre et puis les
enseignants ne veulent absolument pas
que leurs collègues sont montrés du
doigt ce n'est pas un établissement qui
est marquée par la violence et il n'y a
pas d' agression c'est vraiment la
première fois que l'on vit une situation
aussi dramatique ce soir l'hôpital
indique que l'enseignante se trouve dans
un état de santé jugé sérieux mais sa
vie n'est pas en danger
après l'épreuve de philo c'était
aujourd'hui aux élèves de première de
plancher sur le bac français plus de 625
mille candidats et aucun dérapage d'un
incident à signaler reportage algré
furent ans vivant silence on planche ce
matin dans ce lycée des ulis près par il
n'y a pas eu de surprise de dernière
minute les enseignants convoqués pour
surveiller le bac étaient tous là le
proviseur avait prévu du personnel de
remplacement
il n'en a pas eu besoin un dernier mot
d'encouragement aux candidats et les
preuves peut commencer
surtout vous lisez bien le sujet 1 c'est
là qu'est la réussite lisez bien ce
sujet là j'ai respiré un grand coup vous
mettiez au travail vous allez voir c'est
facile vous allez réussir d'accord alors
comment vous senti ce matin
je prends de bakker est normalement
comme ici sur le contrat normal
récemment des candidats stressés juste
ce qu'il faut selon le proviseur ils
n'ont pas souffert des dernières grèves
même si certains cours n'ont pas été
assurés un bon point pour les profs j'ai
pu remarquer que parmi le personnel de
l'enseignant un gréviste
il est quand même malgré tout une
attention particulière à suivre les
élèves à les préparer à l'examen et
c'est un effort conséquent de la part
des personnels est au bénéfice des
élèves
allez on souffle on respire c'est le
week-end les épreuves ne reprennent que
lundi avec au programme histoire géo et
physique-chimie pour les élèves de
terminale et puis on retiendra tout de
cette manifestation de femmes
enseignantes pour la plupart qui ont
occupé la salle des illustres de la
mairie et leurs objectifs et souligné la
situation des femmes face au projet de
réforme des retraites une action
déterminée mais joyeuse qui s'est
achevée vous le voyez dans la bonne
humeur et c'est la reprise dans les
transports un trafic presque normal la
sncf et à la ratp avant le nouveau
mouvement de jeudi prochain journée
d'action à l'appel de quelques
fédérations de cheminots tentant
d'évaluer les conséquences de la grève
sur l'écoulement des marchandises mais
aussi sur la feuille de paie à venir des
grévistes martin gouès michel vasseur
retour sur les rails avec la grève
l'activité marchandises de la sncf
étaient stoppés après neuf jours sans
pratiquement d'activité ce matin le
centre de triage de drancy retrouvé son
aspect habituel
wouah ça ça reprend voilà depuis 6
heures du matin selon ma part dieu
donc ça ressemble à les jours
en nombre en temps normal ce sont par
jour 1800 wagons qui sortent de ce
centre de la semaine dernière on est
tombée à 200 wagons par jour 9 x mois
dans la troisième gare de triage de
france on se prépare à rattraper ce
retard pour les trains qui sont en
attente dans les autres triage c'est sûr
que là pendant une semaine on va avoir
pas mal de l'activité on a moins de
temps de
moi de temps d'attentes entre les trains
et
c'est on essaye d'avoir du personnel en
plus et frei et le froid ces dalles et
d'accélérer le mouvement
du côté des grévistes le retour au
travail ne se fait pas sans difficultés
les derniers jours non travaillés laisse
des traces
si vous avez fait grèce combien de temps
au sein du jour bah oui surtout ceux
d'aujourd'hui quatre enfants par jour
prend d'autant plus sûr du point
la retenue moyenne serait de 53 euros
par jour de grève
une somme est allée à raison de trois
jours par mois pendant trois mois
pour la direction pas question de faire
de cadeaux la grève inquiète une journée
de grève pour le fret peut coûter
peut-être 8 à 10 millions d'euros
et c'est l'ordre de grandeur qu'on a
qu'on à peu près en tête neuf jours de
grève c'est donc une facture d'une
centaine de millions d'euros simplement
pour le fret
objectif maintenant reconquérir les
clients déçus avant qu'ils ne se
tournent vers le principal concurrent la
route
et qu'en est il pour les usagers qui
avaient leur billet en poche les jours
de grève voici ce que propose la sncf
pour les journées à fortes perturbations
celle du 3 4 5 et 10 juin le
remboursement du billet sera intégrale
quant aux journées marquées par des
perdus par des perturbations plan local
les journées concernées sont celles du 6
7 8 9 11 12 et 13 juin
les voyageurs de s'adresser au service
clientèle pour remboursement enfin en
ile-de-france aucune décision n'a été
prise pour l'instant
quand journée quant à marseille la grève
des éboueurs entrant dans son onzième
jour la mairie a décidé le nettoiement
de milliers de tonnes d'ordures sur
réquisition au moment où le mouvement
syndical se fissure les éboueurs force
ouvrière ont voté ce matin la reprise du
travail contrairement à leurs collègues
cfdt reportage
francis mazier l'opération nettoyage de
marseille a déjà commencé avec les
grands moyens
dans la population l'annnonce de la
reprise des éboueurs à la mi journée a
été vécu comme un soulagement et gallas
excusez moi
n'est ce pas me voir le bourg voilà je
suis marseillais de fraîche date si moi
je vous assure j'ai beaucoup voyagé
beaucoup déménagé dans toute la france
jamais vu bill aussi sol sur la rue
paradis qui porte bien mal son nom
depuis 11 jours à cause des tas
d'ordures
certains sont encore ces petits moyens
encore rien de réaliser donc c'est pas
la fin de la grève vous y croyez pas pas
encore non quand moi je vois de mes yeux
je vous dirais oui c'est la fin c'est
après un débat houleux que le syndicat
fo majoritaire a suspendu le mouvement
un baroud d'honneur de la cfdt toujours
en grève ne devrait pas perturber la
reprise le maire qui n'avait pas obtenu
l'intervention de l'armée est satisfait
à la fois je respectais le droit de
grève mais à la fois j'ai à givet avec
fermeté en procédant depuis hier à des
réquisitions
car la ville ne peut pas avec ce manque
d'hygiène cette insalubrité courir des
risques de contamination ou d'épidémie 4
à 5 jours devraient être nécessaires
afin de venir à bout de 8000 tonnes
d'ordures enfin sachez qu'à paris le
mouvement de grève est levé ceci nous
amène à reparler de ce serpent de mer le
service minimum en cas de grève jean
pierre raffarin a redit les engagements
de son gouvernement engagements à venir
sur l'instauration d'un service minimum
les réactions ne se sont pas fait
attendre pauline nos rêves naze et andré
sera jacques chirac on avait fait une
promesse électorale
hier soir c'est jean pierre raffarin qui
a fait le premier pas devant ces patrons
de petites et moyennes entreprises
irrité par les perturbations j'ai bien
entendu votre
message sur le service minimum vous
connaissez les engagements du
gouvernement
vous avez entendu mais ministre je
veille à ce que le climat social reste
dans notre pays le meilleur possible
mais je confirme les engagements
ce premier réaction celle des
socialistes pour eux cette proposition
ne serait qu'une solution en trompe
l'oeil ne sais pas avec un service
minium qu'on réglera la question de la
grève
c'est d'abord avec une bonne négociation
aujourd'hui les communistes sont les
plus virulents pas question de porter
atteinte à un droit fondamental
on ne peut croire m ou alors du coup le
cas clairement qu'elle peut pas assurer
une continuité dans les services publics
notamment aux heures de pointe l'idée
fait son chemin à la ratp syndicats et
direction ont une semaine pour trouver
un accord en cas d'échec un préavis de
grève peut alors être déposés éviter les
blocages les syndicats n'y sont pas tous
opposés mais la cfdt y met une condition
à la sncf la négociation doit s'opérer
au sein de l'entreprise
il me semble que la voix a trouvé dans
cette période là c'est plutôt cette voie
là internes plutôt qu'une mesure
législative qui ne mettraient que le feu
aux poudres chez les cheminots en france
donc pas de service minimum pour le
moment en italie en revanche il doit
être assuré par au moins un tiers des
salariés et pour faire graver il faut
prévenir par écrit au moins dix jours
avant en évoquant hier cette idée de
service minimum le premier ministre a
peut être aussi voulu relancer le débat
jacques chirac devant le congrès mondial
des jeunes agriculteurs à paris a redit
cette détermination de défendre la fac
et la politique agricole commune dont la
réforme est actuellement discuté par les
quinze le chef de l'état a prévenu que
la france n'acceptera pas n'importe quel
aplomb la suite des référendum dans les
pays candidats à l'entrée dans l'union
depuis aujourd'hui c'est au tour des
tchèques de se prononcer sur des
l'adhésion de leur payer le oui devrait
l'emporter selon les derniers sondages
l'ancien président vaclav havel
partisans de l'intégration européenne a
été l'un des premiers à voter champagne
à bruxelles la convention a réussi un
petit tour de force établir un consensus
qui permettra la naissance d'une future
constitution européenne christian mary
mono
et 6 ont d'entrée ensemble dans la
nouvelle europe
je vous remercie et européens
champagne le président giscard d'estaing
met un terme à seize mois de travail
décent cinq membres de la convention un
projet de constitution est né à la
satisfaction générale l'on touche d'une
façon ou d'une autre dit que cette
constitution constituerait un bon cadre
pour l'avenir de l'europe et pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne
ce travail n'a pas été fait
clandestinement secrètement par des
diplomates mais les portes et les
fenêtres étaient ouvertes et note que la
constitution doit être écrite pour le
doyen ordinaires qu'ils croient audio ou
qu'ils n'y croient pas et l'europe sera
une option united
les polonais ont fait leur deuil de
l'absence de dieu dans le texte qu'elles
se contentent d'humour religieux le rock
sera donc demain
constitué d'un président du conseil
européen élu pour deux ans et demi une
commission européenne restreinte à
quinze commissaires mais pas en 2009
enfin de la création d'un ministre des
affaires étrangères qui parlera soyez 25
les travaux de la convention sont
terminées et le projet de constitution
européenne sera proposé au prochain
sommet de thessalonique en grèce la
semaine prochaine mais le plus dur reste
à faire convaincre les gouvernements
mais surtout les citoyens européens ils
se prononceront dans quelques mois par
référendum nouveau raid israélien en fin
de journée à gaza des hélicoptères ont
tiré au moins deux missiles sur une
voiture faisant un mort et 15 blessés il
s'agit du sixième raid depuis mardi par
ailleurs deux israéliennes ont été
gravement blessés par des tirs
palestiniens en cisjordanie un israélien
a été tué par balles ce soir à djénine
dans cette flambée de violence israël
semble déterminé à écraser le hamas
mouvement islamiste palestinien qui
revendique le terrorisme comme principal
moyen d'action le gouvernement d'ariel
sharon s'est engagé dans une guerre
totale avec pour cible désormais les
extrémistes palestiniens du hamas
charles enderlin c'était à gaza les
obsèques des victimes du raid israélien
d'hyères est à nouveau les militants du
hamas et du djihad promettent des
attaques suicide à tel-aviv à jérusalem
paradoxalement les israéliens n'ont pas
toujours considéré les islamistes
palestiniens comme leurs ennemis en 1981
des intégristes expulsés d'egypte ont
été autorisés à revenir à gaza par un
ministre israélien de la défense qui
s'appelait ariel sharon l'année suivante
l'administration militaire a même
participé à la construction de ce
bâtiment sera le siège de l'union
islamique dirigé par hr charismatique à
remédier si les dirigeants israéliens de
gauche comme de droite jouait les
islamistes contre l'ol paie le tournant
interviendra en 1988 lors de la première
intifada
le sjo vient think he et le mouvement
hamas ce qui signifie zèle on sera
arrêté à les suivantes
le hamas se dote d'une branche militaire
et se lance dans la guérilla urbaine et
les attentats son objectif une palestine
islamique de la méditerranée au désert
la disparition d'israël par les attaques
suicides qu'il s'oppose au processus
d'oslo
d'abord affaibli par l'autorité autonome
d'arafat le ramasser renforcer en 1997
par la libération d'un dirigeant dur
abdel aziz al rantissi puis du cheikh
yassine qui retourne à gaza une décision
du premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou l'échec des négociations la
seconde intifada la destruction
systématique des services de sécurité
palestiniens permette or hamas de
prendre le contrôle d'une partie de la
rue en cisjordanie et à gaza selon les
sondages sa popularité dépasserait
aujourd'hui celle du fatah de yasser
arafat ou proposent maintenant ce
document dans la région de bunia au
congo ce livre de violents combats les
milices utilisent depuis des années des
enfants de moins de 12 ans ces enfants
soldats qui portaient des kalachnikovs
ont reçu une formation dès l'âge de dix
ans des enfants soldats qui ont appris à
tuer reportage éric meunier patrick
desmulie frédéric ranque
ils se disent redouter se croit
invulnérable
à 10 12 13 ans ils ont pour modèle les
héros des films d'action américains un
peu comme tous les enfants du monde
mais eux ne jouent pas les simbas les
lions en swahili c'est le nom de cette
unité m qui campe ici aux portes de
bunia l'ennemi lendou est à 2 km ou bien
de 7
on ne sait pas très bien de ses enfants
perdus thomas est le plus érudit le seul
à avoir suffisamment fréquenté l'école
pour s'exprimer en français
moi oui et gère après midi tous beaucoup
aux blessés beaucoup d'avoir bg oui à la
paix si tu les a tuées oui mais tu
presque comme un enfant non c'est
maintenant mais non oui merci je suis en
affaires mais il est peu utilisé sa
tribu comme l'egypte et utilisés
j'ai quand même une force d'utiliser
d'utiliser sa part au gp envers ces
cellules les limites sur sa famille
thomas ne veut pas s'étendre il dit
seulement que les laines doubs ont tué
son père et que là est la raison de son
engagement
thomas tient à faire visiter sa chambre
et une pièce crasseuse dans cette ville
un pilier abandonné devenue le quartier
général des sims
les fêtes c'est pour mieux nous faire
admirer ces dernières dotation le
capitaine bimbo n'a un ancien étudiant
commandes le groupe
il est très fier de ses petits soldats
ils ont battu comme des grands comme des
glands me dépasser les autres nouvelles
habitudes comme ils sont les abeilles
mais avant c'est un âge ils font des
choses rapidement parfois moi je laime
travers des glissements son indiscipline
seulement avec les petits dribbles petty
a time va c'est à neige ne sont pas des
petits ne sais pas nous qui regardent
l'âge de ses enfants
le seul tabou y en ait tuerie on en
trouve dans toutes les milices mais on
sait que cette pratique est condamné par
la communauté internationale
il y avait jours c'est thomas et ses
camarades qui ont repoussé l'offensive
des landes où sur bunia il ne leur font
pas peur
la présence des soldats français en
revanche les intrigues nos voisins
veulent que vous arrêtiez la guerre je
vais quitter sa palette france
oui ça viendra peut-être que je sois
photo oui ça va finir
peut-être que pour aller à l'école avec
les länder non pourquoi
les résultats nadal qui a présidé à tour
à tour où le ballet allégret quand il y
aura la paix mais il l'est ne va pas
laisser il perdra l'école et grâce aux
photos y remédier
quand vous vénale des piles quoi vous
vivez vous égorgez une guerre d'enfants
quelque part dans la brousse un jeune
lendou du même âge nourries sans doute
au même moment la même haine à l'égard
de thomas et de ses compagnies quand on
reparle de la navette spatiale c'est en
recherchant les causes de la catastrophe
de columbia que les experts de la nasa
ont découvert un possible défaut de
structure
de quoi rendre dangereuse les prochaines
missions patrice pollet deux minutes
après le décollage
c'est la séparation des boosters des
propulseurs d'appoint
il s'écarte alors du réservoir principal
après l'explosion contrôlée et
volontaire de boulons voici l'un d'eux
c'est un tube de 20 kg sa position ici
rattaché au réservoir principal en vol
après sa rupture sous l'effet de
l'explosif il va aller se loger dans une
poche
c'est ce réceptacle ce panier qui
aujourd'hui d'après la nasa représente
je cite un défaut potentiellement
catastrophiques pour la navette
nous avons observé que ce compartiment
de récupération on pas aussi robuste que
nous le pensions et une poche pas assez
solide en clair on peut tout craindre
comprendre un accident grave
au moment du décollage près de vingt ans
après le lancement de la première
navette cette découverte fait froid dans
le dos et à la clé se pose cette
question
tous les équipages partis dans l'espace
ont-ils frôler la mort pour l'instant
pas de réponse formelle de la nasa
les trois dernières navettes sont
toujours bloqués au sol c'est demain que
sera inauguré le 45e salon de
l'aéronautique et de l'espace au bourget
un événement qui attire des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs
mais cette année il n'y aura aucune
présentation en vigueur en vol d'avions
de combat russes et américains le salon
du bourget perd un peu de sa superbe
dans cette crise du transport aérien
nicolas chateauneuf patrie c'est cher
lors des derniers entraînements cet
après-midi dans le ciel du bourget avec
cette année une très forte présence dans
le ciel des pays européens
et pour cause depuis la création du
salon ya 50 ans c'est la première fois
qu'aucun avion militaire a mais l'écart
ne fera des démonstrations en vol
mais malgré la décision du pentagone au
sol les etats unis restent largement le
pays le plus représenté
il n'y a jamais eu de brouille franco
américaine en matière d'affaires
il y a une tension politique je prends
que depuis le g8 à evian et commencent à
s'estomper
donc une fois de plus les américains
changent au prochain plan politique des
alliés personnes venant d'auch il y a
deux ans le salon avait battu tous les
records depuis la situation a bien
changé
11 septembre crise du secteur aérien
guerre en irak le moral n'est pas au
beau fixe mais les organisateurs du
salon pratique la méthode coué
contexte général n'est pas le meilleur
il est temps qu'il reste très important
pour tout le monde de préparer l'avenir
et ce salon et participe énormément
loin de ces considérations sur les
stands on peaufine les derniers détails
techniques
c'est hélicoptères tigre suivi donc une
révision complète
définition de ces salles
ce qui est des systèmes embarqués
l'armement et
aujourd'hui les derniers appareils sont
arrivés sur le tarmac avant d'être
exposée aux yeux du public demain tout
doit être prêt pour l'inauguration
il sera alors temps de fêter les 100 ans
de l'aviation large débat jan
l'explosion d'un navire qui venait de
vider ses plus d'un marin a trouvé la
mort lors de la déflagration
le bateau naviguait à vide il n'y a donc
aucun danger de pollution
on ignore les causes de l'accident une
enquête est en cours
l'élan orage hier soir en alsace plus de
200 interventions de pompiers dans les
villages de soule débat nous coulée de
boue a détruit les russes soulevant le
bitume 50 cm d'eau dans les maisons
le terme de maladies orphelines faisait
maintenant familier il s'agit de ces
maladies très rares délaissé par la
recherche de main dans toute la france
se déroulera une opération nez rouge au
profit de l'association qui se bat pour
mieux faire connaître et reconnaître ces
affections souvent graves
l'occasion de suivre ce garçon de 9 ans
alexandre atteint du syndrome de love
josé blanc la pierre que variés se
donner l'illusion de jouer tout seul
c'est l'activité préférée d'alexandre
malgré ses petites mains qui manquent de
force et ses yeux qui distingue à peine
le clavier alexandre est atteint d'une
maladie rare une cataracte des deux yeux
détecter quelques jours après sa
naissance
opéré plusieurs fois jusqu'à l'âge de
trois ans il n'a connu pratiquement que
l'hôpital aujourd'hui à 9 ans ils ne
parlent pas ils marchent seulement
depuis quelques mois une première
victoire obtenue sur la maladie
il propose tous les jours même si assez
à son béton c'est des petites choses
mais un mais il nous fait plaisir nous
fait plaisir on est fier de lui home est
fière de toi l'ex voilà donc bientôt bas
on l'espère que qui pourra nous parler
je pense bien comprendre mais ce sont
des attitudes qui peut avoir des mini du
visage
il ne s'exprime pas moi c'est un petit
garçon prétend tu me fais un bisou bisou
alexandre parlera-t-il un jour comment
sa maladie va-t-elle évoluer
aucun médecin ne possède la réponse car
ce handicap
le syndrome de l'homme n'est connu que
depuis dix ans les seuls concernés par
une maladie qu'on ne connaît pas c'est
on est tout seul rumba ces langues une
angoisse
non c'est à vous d'aller de choix
de faire des recherches pour tous pour
savoir comment comment on va pouvoir le
prendre en charge qui va pouvoir
s'occuper de lui quels projets on va
pouvoir faire pour lui pour sa vie pour
son avenir
comment aider alexandre agrandir ses
parents se démène tout seul pour réunir
l'argent nécessaire à la recherche sans
aucune aide de l'état pour une maladie
qui concerne moins de 50 familles en
france la qualité sportive avec du
tennis c'est de bonne augure quelques
jours avant wimbledon le français
sébastien grosjean a battu cet après
midi en quarts de finale du tournoi du
queen's
le numéro un mondial lleyton hewitt 6 3
6 4
une belle performance pour vosges en
face à spécialiste de la surface sur
herbe
les 24 heures du mans avec comme thème
les dangers de la vitesse cette année
les performances des voitures ont été
réduites
reste cette incroyable impression de
course folle encore dans les esprits
avec les accidents de ces dernières
années yvan martin et 24 heures du mans
99 dans la ligne droite
la mercedes numéro 5 décolle
littéralement avant de s'écraser en
bordure du circuit
son pilote sort indemne de l'accident un
an plus tôt nikkei mais sa porsche 911
finissent dans le public là encore
miraculeusement pas de blessés mais au
mans tous les accidents n'ont pas connu
une fin si heureuse henri pescarolo s'en
souvient encore j'ai décollé dans la
ligne droite des hunaudières
époque où il n'y avait pas driver fait
ressembler directement dans les sapins
et si je suis en train de vous parler
c'est un miracle a eu lieu il ya eu
aucun autre pilote qui soit sorti il y
aura une saison pourtant le danger c'est
justement ce qui a rendu cette course si
mythique la peur ici c'est l'autre
carburant des pilotes
la course est dangereux c'est ce qui
nous passionne
on a en a toujours 7 c'est ce goût du
risque qui fait on a à chaque moment où
le sport automobile est dangereux et le
5e 24 heures évidemment alors au mans
désormais les voitures sont moins
rapides
fini les kilomètres de lignes droites la
performance est à présent limité
dernière nous avons décidé au mans de
réduire de 10% les bruits donc de façon
à réduire de 10% les performances des
voitures
demain les voitures n'iront pas à 400 km
heure comme avant les a340 maximum le
prix de la sécurité
c'est demain à bercy que se déroulera le
grand prix de kickboxing une compétition
de boxe vous l'avez compris mais d'un
genre particulier puisqu'on peut
utiliser ses pieds et ses points un
combat très proches de ceux des jeux
vidéo ce qui explique peut-être
l'engouement des jeunes pour ce sport et
cette discipline le meilleur français
s'appelle jérôme le banner un guerrier
christophe duchiron si l'on revient à
admettre que le ring et une basse cour
alors jérôme le banner est un beau petit
poulet est un poulet poids lourd quand
même 120 kg 1 mètre 90 avec des
principes et des pieds qui font mal
plaisir d'offrir joie de recevoir tel
est en quelque sorte la devise de cette
discipline tout en délicatesse la
formule 1 des sports de combat aux dires
de ceux qui s'y connaissent en marron en
châtaignes et en bourre pifs ces partis
chacun
si on est là à brutes épaisses de 20
matchs de quatre chemins on va falloir
vie sur un fil au vestiaire avec deux
bleus c'est pendant que non plus donné à
tout le monde mais je crois que tous en
effet il en va des sciences les plus
pointus comme de la boxe pieds-poings
tout est une question de cerveau doté
d'un style spectaculaire et guerrier
jérôme le banner est devenue l'une des
attractions du genre au japon le pays
roi du cac avec lui les adversaires
tombent comme des mouches
une fois il a mis un dénommé jésus chaos
et le valeureux ne s'en est pas relevé
l'idole des jeunes au japon le français
surnommé geronimo est devenu le héros
d'un jeu vidéo qui permet à tous les
hommes de mon gabarit de se prendre pour
jérôme le banner qui fait rêver un peu
le temps d'une partie surtout quand on
gagne samedi à bercy on annonce salle
comble les huit participants
s'affronteront à chaque match en trois
rounds de trois minutes
les âmes sensibles trouveront ça
barbares les autres viendront voir
jérôme le banner et le gladiateur drôle
d'époque plus paisible l'art du jardin
ce week end dans le parc de saint cloud
avec cette année l'installation dans les
arbres d'un radeau des cimes
les enfants pourront ils découvrirent
haut perché à monde inhabituel
marie-pierre ce luthier creux barnier
c'est le dernier modèle du radeau des
cimes pour l'installer il a fallu
trouver une grande surface d'arbres
assez solides pour le porter 400 m² de
filet sur une ossature gonflables enfin
naître l alsacien une fois que s'est
posée comme vous pouvez le constater on
installe en fait des système de cordage
et donc avec des systèmes de mousquetons
et de l'onj on assure la sécurité des
personnes qui utilisent cette structure
pour grimper sur la cime des arbres
il va falloir s'équiper qu'est ce qui
vient avec nous alors on s'harnache
enfileront ce casque il on se concentre
pour oublier le vertige a ensuite on
escalade
c'est dans cet espace privilégié que se
déroule la plupart des phénomènes
biologiques les plus intéressants il ya
beaucoup de plantes d'insectes d'oiseaux
ya une vie extrêmement là haut c'est la
canopée cet endroit qui sépare la forêt
de l'atmosphère
les scientifiques étudient grâce au
radeau des cimes les insectes et les
phénomènes biologiques les plus
intéressants équilibriste d'un jour
les enfants découvrent grâce au radeau
un autre monde les à peine sont-ils
redescendu sur le plancher des vaches
qui l'ont déjà envie d'y retourner
le radeau des cimes flottera ici jusqu'à
lundi avant de repartir avec les
chercheurs en amazonie nous avons appris
il ya tout juste une heure guy lux
c'était un l'âge de 84 ans il aura
marqué le monde de la télévision célèbre
présentateur d' intervilles
on lui doit une multitude d'émissions de
jeux et de variétés évocation marilyn
bono a mis dedans à l'est de bayonne et
ami de notre jeu intervilles
rappelez-vous les courses de vachettes
les joutes oratoires avec léon zitrone
c'était à l'époque l'émission la plus
regardée et pardonner kovacs a enlevé de
cocardes encore avec interviews dans
1962 guy lux inventé l'un des premiers
jeux à grand spectacle en direct ce qui
réserve est souvent bien des surprises
enfin je déclinais ensuite en interne
âge avec pour complice cette fois simone
garnier
merci simone d'obtenir suivons pas voyez
je me rends utile premier ce premier
arius à inventer des dizaines et des
dizaines d'émissions à une époque où
l'audimat n'existait pas du schmilblick
à sport dimanche en passant par le
palmarès des chansons samedi et ajouts
top club
lotodimanche et bien d'autres encore la
légende veut que je sans frontières
diffusé en 1965 lui était essoufflé par
le général de gaulle qui parait-il ne
ratait jamais intervilles et en 1969
c'était un nouveau jeu et passons
maintenant donc à ce schmilblick qui
vaut huit cent quarante mille anciens
francs avant même la première question
un objet à découvrir à quillan rapport
ce schmilblick avec la gastronomie
je voudrais en 1967 c'était le palmarès
des chansons tout ce qu'il mettait à
l'antenne il réussissait avec la coutume
de dire que les gens qui réussissent
vraiment réussi c'est parce qu'ils ont
de la chance
après avoir occupé l'écran pendant plus
de trente ans il se retirait de
l'antenne dans les années 90 mais
continuer de produire à cause de son
talent j'ai ma tristesse parce que je
crois que j'ai réussi merci mon dieu
la conversion de celui qui un jour ceni
30 ans 32 en images ça suffit mais le
style du lycée georges hilux l'un des
pionniers de la télévision disait de lui
même qu'il était un robinet à idées
maintenant nous allons vous rendre
l'antenne au revoir pour la première
fois en france une grande exposition au
musée galliera est consacrée à marianne
il est riche sa garde-robe à son
élégance se fige audit et d'armes
c'est l'histoire d'une starlette qui a
créé son personnage construit son propre
mythe mister ellis marler femme fatale à
l'écran garçonne à la ville elle
contrôle ti lumière maquillage et
garde-robe avec une centaine de
vêtements et de photos le musée galliera
bresse l'inventaire détaillé de son
bestiaire tribu ce n'est pas une accro
de la mode c'est quelqu'un qui achètent
ce qu'ils vivent à ce qui correspond à
ce qu'elle ressent donc ça peut être des
choses très simples très sobre dépouillé
assez différent à la ville de son conte
la mivoie porté à l'écran
dans les années 30 - les codes de la
bonne société c'est en complet veston
que marne elle se rend au studio de
cinéma à hollywood
et lorsqu'elle apparaît en smoking aux
côtés de maurice chevalier gary cooper
et fait scandale par sa bisexualité
afficher les rayons
quand elle chante pour les soldats elle
l'aristocrate allemande devenue
résistante au nazisme s'habille aussi
bien en uniforme militaire qu'en robe de
chambre haute couture
après la guerre marlène devient beaucoup
plus féminine c'est le temps de sa
liaison avec gabin l'homme de sa vie
dior chanel balenciaga les plus grands
noms la bille mais toujours avec
sobriété et puis c'est la chanteuse qui
l'emportent son actrice elle va
elle-même concevoir des costumes de
scène robes à écailles de poisson
manteaux en plumes de coq inspiré de ses
films avec sternberg toujours en
représentation marlène des fiches s'est
créé un style unique avec la liberté
d'une femme moderne ni anges mi démons
se termine ce journal dans un instant un
métier onatel dirais oui puis le point
route vers humoristes amateurs 55
boulevard du palais 22h50 contre-courant
le pen vous et moi
un documentaire de serge moati 01 25 le
dernier journal elle mettait quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
deux des 13 heures je vous remercie de
votre attention que s'élancent en soirée
sur france 2 on se quitte avec ses
images de lièvre le châtel ce village
fortifié du loiret vient d'obtenir le
label d'un des plus beaux villages de
france